when you get onto a project it's kind of
a collaborative sort of discussion
especially with designing the looks that
normally you talk about that with your
producers and directors and then I will
go off and do lots of research
especially because I tend to do lots of
period dramas so I always take on the
the period of what I'm going to take on
and then I research and then I mood
board quite a lot of my ideas even
before I get any any cast on board
that's to give just a sort of a feel of
where I'm going to take the hair and
makeup I do both I do hair and makeup
and prosthetics I I find I could not I
find it hard to just design say just the
makeup or the hair I like to see the
whole picture and then also it's a
collaborative with costume as well it's
is you need to sort of work with with
production design it's kind of I see
them all kind of linking together as
well so it's not not just about myself I
tend to like working with costume
designers as well to kind of get an
overall feel of where I'm going and that
I'm pitching correctly with the director
yogi you'll also have brings something
to the table as well and show his share
his ideas he'll normally do kind of a
brief outline of characters and certain
things it depends also if it's a
recreation of what you're doing or a
remake of a drama that's already been
done that's another thing to take into
consideration or you're going to try and
make it your own and make it different
which is very quite important and
actually quite hard to do then when the
actors come on board I would show them
my mood boards and then I would
collaborate with them because obviously
an artist will bring something to the
table and they they will then will
either light your ideas or they bring
something to know from that they will
also put their input in so it does take
a little bit of time sometimes it won't
you'll get it like that other times it
takes a little bit of work and then
you've got the physicalities of say
you've got an idea for a character and
you might think oh my god I want I see
her as a blonde
especially for a lady and they come and
they've got short hair and they've got
red hair then you it's a bit more of a
process and you're hoping that the
timing of everything will slot into
place it's quite quite a magical process
and sometimes it could would be very
smooth and sometimes it can not be so
smooth and you have to consider that all
these things know what do I do when I
wake this person will I go and get their
hair color changed and it's quite
interesting you know facial hair with
the guy's haircuts wigs
it's a process prosthetics as well so
that's that's kind of how it kind of
evolves really I started my background I
started a little bit more in the films
and quite prosthetic based and also I'm
a hairdresser from previous by trade
period was something I kind of ended up
kind of falling into and I think a lot
of that I think the big break for me was
when I did Hunger because it was a
period drum although I've lived that
period which was the something of the
70s 80s 70s from that piece of work I
think put me on kind of on the map of
doing that and then I got more offers in
period it just went from there and I
really enjoy it's slightly different
from contemporary but I think the
process are the same I wouldn't I'm not
going to say one is easier than the
other period is harder because maybe you
proxy would have more wigs within that's
not necessarily true because even
contemporary you might have to wick
somebody or could we create a look so I
think they both habits it's it's
different different strengths and
different dilemmas I think I think
things have changed it's I first started
out when I first say started prosthetics
it was a lot of it was done with foam
latex and now we've gone on to this
wonderful silicon process silicone is
amazing we've got Pro Bondo's which of
these wonderful scars that come very
quick to do now for wounds but some of
the old fashioned techniques I still
love I love blood I'm a big fan of blood
and gore and I don't know why but I just
I just loved that creation you can have
a lot of fun with it and I think you
just got to keep him trying to improve
and there's always room for improvement
it's kind of my one thing I do enjoy it
I do like working overseas because you
get to meet people maybe somewhere like
Russia that hasn't got certain resources
and come up with some amazing stuff from
literally using their imagination they
haven't got the luxury of lots of make
up shops
everyone has their
they're great people which I've had the
pleasure to work with some of them which
is great
gunpowder was an interesting journey I
have a theory sometimes that crowd is a
very different baby to main team crowd
is a different a very different art main
team is just it's just a different pace
a different way and for me it was very
hard sometimes to get a crowd supervisor
on sometimes the smaller projects where
they expect main team to do that work
and sometimes it's you can do but
sometimes you can't do that every day so
it physically becomes impossible and I
also believe in very strong planning of
a lot of the period hairstyles you have
to have worked if you have to do your
fittings which I think sometimes I mean
I could not imagine running a crowd room
when you've got no stock that's pre-prep
pre-prepared and and without having
luxury time to dress them because you
haven't got the budget to have them pre
dress so you have to kind of do it
in-house so how I plan gunpowder with it
was I got a great team of people I'd
sourced the stock quite cheaply that
obviously Elizabethan styling is very
curly very phrased so I spent quite a
few days sourcing wigs that we could do
that and I actually went on a fro
because we did a lot of afro wigs in
creating the shape so I had a wonderful
team of people to come and dress for me
lovely Rupert Simon I had Rowena Dean I
had Jackie Sweeney had Laura Diwani a
season new book we all sat and we did
they did the dressing so they bought a
lot into the Elizabethan hair styling
from the women that the people have to
see what you're doing and then I shop
for everything all the accessories and
tried to make it look a bit you know
make it our own but also with the period
as well after doing all the research
pearls obviously Elizabethan pearls is
very important and jewels so we did that
ourselves actually yeah we have the
story is part of our history yeah it was
it was the writing and and the story and
then knowing that kit was involved and
his background because he was part of
there's the Catesby he's descendants
from the Kate Spears my initial thing
was what am I going to do to make him
from the Game of Thrones character of
Jon Snow I did talk to him about that
but obviously I couldn't do too much
with him but what I did do was I said to
him your your hair on Jon Snow it's
quite dark and when I met him I said
would you mind if I just got your hair
slightly lightened a little bit for this
you can always go back it won't be
detrimental to his hair he just did what
we called balayage just through the top
which just pre lightens a little bit so
that when the light hit is here it did
have kind of a lovely red tinge to the
hair and I turned him a little bit
because Jon Snow's always kept very pale
so I thought well I'll just make him as
if he was an outside type of chap riding
all the time weathered a bit more so
that's the approach that it was very
small but I felt like I made a bit of a
difference if he done something don't
get too upset if it doesn't doesn't
doesn't work and well we haven't had Liv
Tyler on board playing and though
and again this woman was a woman of the
Bible she actually did embrace the fact
that the star was plain not that
elaborate and and she she went for it
which I was thought maybe she'd bought a
bit more twee and I said to it she's a
Puritan we want her completely pure so
we didn't over glamorize her at all so
that's also I think a good good way of
doing it but I mean I just want to say
one thing going back to gunpowder when
you asked me about my team I actually
then had to have there was myself and my
supervisor and then I managed to get a
crowd supervisor but didn't work all the
time but actually the rest of my team
were based on three brilliant trainees
who was Julia Finch at least Lisa and
Celia who were Chinese I gave them a
chance because I could see that they had
initiative and the fact they would then
they were a little bit I was quite lucky
in chasing them in a way because they
were a little bit more than trainees but
they actually did themselves really
proud and did some amazing work I think
for youngsters heading to it on today if
you can find a designer that you like
and you never know I don't mind being
pestered when people ring me up as
they pestered but no no I get lots of
people writing but you sometimes you can
have a lucky day so and these are the
future makeup artists when you get good
trainees they are actually worth their
weight in gold and they end up working
they do work really really hard but you
learn so much and there and you've got
the youth on your side the energy on
your side so and you've just got to take
it on board and be brave and and don't
don't feel scared we had eight weeks to
shoot it they knocked a week off that's
quite a quite tight on an honor on an
eight week you know to get three
episodes in eight weeks that's not not
long the weather wasn't great we had
lots of mud and and sometimes it was
hard we had lots of effects lots of
blood quite a bit of crowd so we were
all.we all muscled in to be honest so I
think you know hopefully the the output
spoke for itself and it was a talked
about show for whatever reasons you know
the gore the the believability of it it
caused a stir so I feel quite proud of
our little little project and our team
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]